[Music]
a new location a new year a new mystery
to solve
oh no we're not doing that I thought
this was a review of Max Payne it is
doesn't Max Payne have a voice-over
narration that's only for the silly game
this is the movie we need to be a lot
more serious oh my god that dark creepy
angel that I've been hallucinating it
must be related to that drug that makes
people super powerful so how's the
narration - silly again stop with the
jokes voice we have absolutely no sense
of humor in this at all Billy because
the sovereign looks totally ridiculous
it can't be because it's dark and grey
and frowns and grey and dark boots and
gray
in fact it's so great even the walls are
grey you think that's such a good idea
people weirdly take their wall colors
very seriously exactly everything must
be taken seriously and now I must move
on to the incredible mystery of what
happened to Malcolm why what did happen
to milk he got lost because our studio
is too big
I bet you're gonna kick a lot of ass and
take a lot of names see ya
if you mean sitting around and doing a
lot of talking
I did not how did you confuse the two
I'm sorry boys but this is how max pain
is done now what you'd think it'd be a
lot of one-liner shooting in bullet time
exactly that yes no but we do have a
pg-13 rating based on the third-person
shooter from 2001 about detective giving
revenge for his murdered family Max
Payne tries to capture the graphic novel
style and story that made this one of
the most kick-ass games when it came out
it had film noir dialogue comic book
artwork a great sense of humor and even
bullet time when you could slow down the
action whenever you wanted nowadays that
doesn't sound like much but back then
it's a pretty big deal a mere seven
years too late the film adaptation was
released and from the trailers it look
like it was right on track it would open
a top dark goofy but all badass is that
what we actually got in this movie well
let's get this meme out of the way what
No
let's see how max payne went to max
payne it's funnier if you see that's
nova ha ha let's take a look at max
payne
oh sorry I gotta wait for a second there
we go my pain I don't believe in heaven
I believe in pain ooh someone so welcome
to Marwin ten movies credit it starts
out pretty solid with a voice-over
narration beautifully cliched dialogue
and a setup so overly dramatic even
Sunset Boulevard will be telling him to
buy a puppy I could feel the dead down
there just below my feet you'll find
it's a slow burn to a snis though as we
cut to the one week earlier building I
never get my packages on time where this
is the cold case officer
thanks movie the side didn't tip me off
you can give me more hints if you want
that's a pen dad's a dead Max Payne
dad's a file holder so what's the story
his wife and kid were murdered they
never found the guy wow that was so much
more powerful than showing it to us in
the intro of the game I got chills when
he said that hit back the point the game
could go back and incorporate that style
to that big reveal no no no no he said
no it was sad you want a coffee were out
remember when you were a kid and you'd
hold your breath when you run past the
graveyard i think only you did that just
leave that man alone hey guess what the
game designer said when they read the
script
meanwhile in deep max tricks we see
Payne is trying to get mugged so he can
get some answers on a lead yo homie
that's a really nice watch kinda reminds
me of one I lost hung it up on 128 a few
hours ago you a cop or somethin
most deeds just robbed people but I find
these guys give interesting and pleasant
conversation though they do take a long
amount of time to actually commit the
robbery increasing the chances of
getting caught and or distracted so your
personality less protagonist can kick
your ass I just don't get four stars and
uber thugs what you open your eyes you
ever seen this woman you know things are
going back by the way I loved you in
party monsters seriously underrated
one of the thugs tries to run as we see
we're just beginning this terrifying
journey into the world of probate
beneficiaries and goblins mr. wells fine
fine no goblins these monsters
loosen ations in his head as well as a
good distraction from the Train
as Max trapped by the sleazeball from
every movie you've ever seen in your
life just call them Leisure Suit lazy a
little offended I didn't get my
invitation well I set out in the tape I
told you go fine bills partner god I
love those parties where people kind of
dancing kind of talk so it's a nice beat
right not full-on dancing but just kind
of moving my shoulders music how do I
need a boyfriend listen you don't give
me a new name I'm gonna start frisking
every one of your friends you notice by
the way Mark Wahlberg is operating at
half Wahlberg he's not disinterested but
he's not really all that into it either
he's still out there somewhere
what do you mean know what happened to
her then it means it was your
follow-through an unsolved murders I
don't have much hope for that girl in
the alley he's somewhere in between
Planet of the Apes in that atm
a partner was killed too we're both
looking for the same person if I'm more
interested in him talking to gumball
about cable service we have a problem I
got an e all of Trevor's friends Maxima
Tasha Natasha max she's spreche n' but
they're interrupted by her sister played
by badass Mila Kunis sorry I can't say
that without the giggles don't act like
you can don't get me wrong
Mila Kunis can be a very good actress
even a great one but like any performer
she needs to be cast in the right role
what a fuck and trying to be an
intimidating weapons expert at three
footing nothing looking like Audrey
Plaza voicing grumpy cat sounded like
may Griffin isn't gonna cringe any
spines
kneel down Neela fuck down you need to
talk about my sister though I'm not
gonna like she does look pretty cool
next to it you'd be barrel for truth
Kentucky straight bourbon
oh Christ why is that hot Kunis sees
he's a cop and backs off as he continues
to search the Riddler's party and find
some people taking move raspberry
slow-mo he comes across this guy though
[Music]
waiting for him to kiss first do
something did you see my but she saves
him from Fernando's advances but she
feels something is up on her way back
home Bowen for God's sakes bring pants
Frank Miller snow is surprisingly
freezing no I won't be an i Frankenstein
we cut to a shot of Max Payne putting on
his coat thank God for that shot of Max
Payne putting on his coat what the fuck
was that I was called over by another
cop named Alex I need you to look at
something
that's my siren ain't it and heat okay
get out happened to them her just one it
looks like Natasha's found in pieces but
because this is pg-13 and always sees
the arm of Laura Palmer as you probably
noticed by now there's no longer any
narration absolutely no humor honestly
there's not even any personality it's
just max going from scene to scene
performing run-of-the-mill cliche after
run-of-the-mill cliche now don't get me
wrong
the game was cliche after cliche - but
it was over the table and it tried to
really push as many of them in there as
possible that was part of the fun it was
go big or go home
maybe not home but he's here all the
questions I get about my old partner
well good thing you got my back then huh
I did everything everything I did
grounded for life man those are some
rough reviews I've read I'll give Kunis
credit that her best acting is when
she's not talking and she's shooting her
death Claire I'm sorry I didn't do
anything how'd she do that
dude wasn't it just raining like that
very same day so he's like a game of sim
weather I don't think I'll never mind it
will be Alex he walks into Alex's place
fine he's been murdered and someone else
is trying to kill him
still dad he wakes up in the hospital
next to wizard and sidekicks phenomenon
Beau Bridges there's some water deeds on
said they don't even have them in focus
dispatch can razor they found out from
Christa where he car I do hate it when a
movie forgets to put glasses on there
yeah the whole Force has you pegged as
the prime suspect yeah you tell them
where to find me
we dissolve from bored and angry
Wahlberg to bored and confused Wahlberg
yes he attends the funeral Alex and
gives his condolences to his wife damn s
let's sound like Indiana Jones punching
a Nazi what have you done max
[Music]
what does Max Payne done I don't know
this movies so boring it's hard to
follow so everyone thinks max killed
Alex and Natasha that's why an entire
building of cops stand up yet none of
them actually stopped him from going
into Alex's office back up but we stood
through it we have done more than stood
up even if we could I still want to
stood up
ah I understand you're editing there
it's symbolic that they both like
kicking how much hallmark movies no can
the city get so wait it's snowing yet
it's hot enough to melt the snow into
falling water just don't get drunk and
decide to anal fin h er drop it shithead
that's matt shithead you need to talk
about my sister almost probably the last
person who saw her alive except for the
guy that left his wallet laying by ur
body
my mommy says this is my angry voice and
I'm not afraid to use it with Natasha
Kolchak
don't say her name you know for two
relatively cool actors that was some
dorky staging he stops a club just to
pull her gun closer to him
like he's thinking haha oh yeah yeah
what I do for a living you try anything
and I'll kill you
oh sorry I thought that was a line free
for the spy who dumped me up yeah that
was really intimidating okay she's got
the glare we established that they go
inside to find a lead and Natasha's
killer just relax it looks like you're
acting with passion none of that here
oh yeah go silent we need it for this
incredibly dramatic moment of guy we've
known for 70 seconds dying or maybe it
was just done to show off this effect
with looking back kind of looks like a
90s anti-drug commercial so your friends
say marijuana's going to take it places
back why is this guy's entire
performance just looking down at shit is
it because when you get down to eye
level he's like uh what me dunno GO
train you wonder the Mario ghosts
want to get this tattoo what does it
mean that's a Norse Valkyrie Valkyries
fly over the battlefield picking out the
righteous dead a soldier's angel you
know if you were to tell me the most
interesting guy in a Max Payne movie
would be the tenth new artist I'd ask if
someone from Miami Ink goes wrote this
the only way you get to go to heaven to
die in violence which by the way forty
minutes and we've had none uh there's a
short fight and a guy who jumps off
that's it we never see anything else
it's all off-screen you know it's called
bullet time because actual bullets are
seen I guess it'd make more sense if you
were like hey he missed it was sad you
want a bagel out of those two
Christ's evil ways interrogating a guy
he's still looking down on him his
chiropractor says he's gonna get Batman
Begins poster syndrome ever had the
squishy meat entirely of syrup
if you survive please come again
Kunis visit so guys you think she can
get some answers from but how can you
trust a person who cave and apply his
own scar makeup convincingly see if they
know anything about a detective Max
Payne
knocks pain he's looking for something
that God wants to stay he did that's
what makes him even more dangerous
indeed a cop looking for something is
very rare it's like a construction
worker next to a highway construction
site we always hear about it but we
never see it open their wings feathers
and they look like a soldier's angel I
thought the big one place Oh things are
really heating up uh he notices the
wings also that a seer is a Nordic word
but he's a detective he can't figure
that out
we finally get to see what happened to
Max's family but again seeing how they
already mentioned it without showing you
like in the game there's nothing really
shocking about it
I dare even say it's kind of pointless
to show now the most shocking thing is
Max's gosh-darn happiest cop in the
world demeanor coming home underpaid and
overworked to a crying baby who's
driving his wife insane let's be honest
if there was inner monologue in the rest
of this movie it'd be Lydon I came home
drunk as hell Jack Daniels is my
Ovaltine then what's this horseshit I
thought they smile like that was elbow
deep and his shit and he pissed in my
mouth in my goddamn mouth and whatever
it just keeps smiling you know you're
dead inside what I wouldn't give to have
my old life back ooh I'm making lemonade
out of these lemons ah he named his baby
baby it's like those dog owners they
have the word dog randomly hanging up
it's so establishes their identity he
was maybe 10 minutes too late well
halfway through the movie they're
finally focusing on what motivates the
main character I guess we can start - I
hear you're looking for Malcolm I am
well let's get going then wait if we're
gonna do this we're gonna do it right
[Music]
it's snowing in here yes I choose to
have little reaction to that you'll fit
in fine
[Music]
nope
[Applause]
[Music]
I couldn't believe it how could Malcolm
have gotten this lost I didn't know hey
know in tomorrow but you had some in the
beginning yeah so did the movie and
nothing stopped so we're stopping it's
not very consistent I was just thinking
the same thing
thank you right everybody shut up or
shut it whatever inner voices do
[Music]
Dental boner we should have known you're
behind this I'm sorry I can't have Jeff
walk no Malcolm you dumbass oh I know
where he is
yeah where is he Oh wouldn't you like to
know
yes well then let's find out
[Applause]
there you've got guns we've got guns
one way to service yeah and we both know
what it is
sorry told him the bathroom isn't down
that way you have to make a left and he
didn't believe me and so he made a right
I asked you do I want someone
trustworthy no not at all
you know I'm so glad we sat down and
talked about this can you imagine we
just came in guns a-blazing shooting
each other and a thrilling action
sequence that's all I ever think about
actually well critic you continue the
review and I'll continue being this side
character that's completely useless Max
Payne would be proud of you oh you could
do the Mila Kunis death stare Jamie like
this so after slowly morphing into John
Cena we cut two in one week in went from
snow to rain four times
let me change my ass this has got to
employment role act what is it Jason I
just thought you should be aware wait is
that Chris O'Donnell no no it what a
random appearance he does so little in
this role so I'm not entirely sure why
he's here it's so out of nowhere it
makes so little sense I half expect the
dialogue to be it's Batman and Robin not
Robin in Batman it's like seeing someone
as random as ludicrous Papa you should
hear the kind of things max is saying no
that makes any sense he's gotten in his
head that someone here at the company is
responsible it's like coming from one
close above you to an almost identical
closeup of you it's just madness or
should I say Ludo please they had a key
the UK to his credit he has a slightly
larger role than O'Donnell as another
detective trying to find Payne thinking
he's gone AWOL but much like Payne he's
a friggin dumbass when it comes to
identifying the obvious bad guy I'm
worried he's gonna get into another
situation before I can convince him to
come in so you really think he's I think
and he defined him find him with bullets
lots of bullets in the areas that keep
him alive max thinks he can get some
answers from O'Donnell's character
proving even his interrogations are on
permanent
hey Jackie hi I know it's a nitpick but
even the way he threw that phone was
kind of lame girl I guess I loved you in
The Bachelor I can knock more should I'm
gonna knock more I mean cops to continue
knocking well Tonto explains that the
drug being developed makes people super
powerful but also forces them to have
hallucinations the exact same
hallucinations coincidentally the rest
suffered horrible hallucinations Devils
demons you know it's that one chemical
weird gargoyle shit oxide everybody
always sees the same thing after taking
that they said in the SWAT team
because a guy who barely shot a gun in
this movie is a major threat but the
killer Donnell proving that they're in
on the scheme
thank God they can't hit much else
[Music]
how many do you guys have your gun set
to hit behind I didn't order that way I
keep hitting behind him of his speaking
Tasmanian devil he gets away and ooh
Mila Kunis has a gun guess she's finally
gonna be in on the action and haha we're
talking introducing Valkyr the strength
of freedom that's what this is about a
drug well yeah a lot of crime related
things involve drugs
it's like saying that's what this affair
was about sex so he goes to a secret
hideout called Ragnarok brilliantly
disguised as you can see as he's
discovered by some guards you know I've
never craved and naming your gun
dialogue as much as I have now hey you
ever named your gun Tara do what do you
call it dude nothing funny in this movie
the slo-mo doesn't have to be that slow
the idea is the slower it goes the
cooler the stunt should look falling
backwards weirdly enough isn't that cool
a stunt you know what let's have a race
who'll win first Mark Wahlberg falling
backwards with a swath from Zootopia
getting a laugh out sloth Winston how is
it possible to miss that much you have a
freaking sight on your gun use it
because you're mistaking a cool a stand
for your main target that chair looks
for climb but it's not like Wahlberg
it's just falling super slowly again
they just don't know the interesting
things to slow down he's confronted by
Baldy Vaughn no sweat and after all the
build-up we'd better get a damn good
fight with this guy you know he's just
thinking to himself I could have gotten
a transformers paycheck instead of this
what am I kidding they're both thinking
that maybe he's saved by bridges but
what a twist he was the bad guy had to
talk to her sure my side before she took
it to someone else was that happen
though once I realized I could use the
strength of my hands to keep one thing
from being taken away from me his acting
is turning to Alec Baldwin from SNL when
he's not playing Trump Michelle was the
first problem in my life small enough to
reach out and start Lord I need to talk
to you you can't let Tina go out there
with that woman so they uncuff him you
heard right
uncuff him so they can tie him to an
anchor I'm going to place him in an
easily escape yeah that as he of course
it's gage but jumps into the freezing
water bringing us back to where we
started and you know having seen the
story that led up to this moment I think
I can safely say I actually know less
about him than when I started off
seriously before I at least knew the
game character who was a cool poetic one
viewing badass and this guy was none of
those things have replaced it with that
Zulu squat so we're actually in the red
when it comes to what we know about him
maybe those were the phrase negative
personality comes from because it takes
away more than it gives he's the
antimatter of character studies but he
refuses death by drowning to get revenge
because the spirit is a great source to
rip off as he takes the drug to turn
into one of those superhumans which
always sees all those crazy-ass visions
that was adorable that scream was so
silly Ike I don't want to put other
cartoony yells in there
so he goes on a killing spree in Max
Payne that seems weird and he tries to
get his revenge on bridges the drug also
has a selfie stick apparently before
well I was in Free Willy escape to
Pirates Cove that's pain everybody is it
everything you thought of me or even
more fired a gun did you see I'm badass
now I'm sure we can work something out
you're wondering no that wasn't slow-mo
he was actually dumb enough to reach for
his gun
that's lowly hair is challenged people
like you to erase bridges searches for a
way to get out but get scorned
yeah it's Mark Wahlberg versus the
lesser Lebowski it's the showdown we've
all been waiting for
the SWAT team circles around him and
that's it so much was gained like an
appreciation to spend your money better
at this point not much rather watch this
pain alright that pain any day actually
that one's not too bad everyone's like
oh it's Fame away it's copy bad but it
was actually pretty good looking color
beige you know that's what he was still
pretty funny and everything and just
give this a go a little bit my part of
that Max Payne doesn't give what fans
are looking for it's not unique enough
to give movie goers what they're looking
for and the majority of it is boring ass
in that this movie's been allowed to
really go over-the-top crazy I mean not
Legion over-the-top crazy but awesome
action film noir over-the-top crazy this
could have been a very enjoyable stylish
Flair as is it's just a doll exercising
snow
with an occasional good shot here and
there but what does that matter when
there's absolutely no substance and no
fun to back it up the mystery still
remains though where is Malcolm I think
this might explain things a bit hey guys
it's Malcolm I'm just giving a heads-up
I'm not back from my vacation yet I had
a few things get in the way so it's
going to delay me getting back to film
the next episode it's not so
inconvenient
I've actually been kidnapped well the
question still remains are you gonna
change that walk away they cut off a
couple of my toes and sent it to those I
loved most I figured you guys wouldn't
be in the mix don't you think the
viewers might get upset they'd say if
they don't get $20,000 they're gonna cut
off my testicles with toothpicks you
know some people might get uneasy by
this but you know a lot of people have
to realize that change is a normal part
of life I think there was even talk
about surgically giving me a third
testicle just so they can take away
another we know when they find a living
with a new wall color isn't the end of
the world right now they're gambling for
who gets to chop off my budget to live
with a lot of other things I know one of
them really wants to wear them as a
helmet perhaps discover a new level of
patience empathy love a new way of
looking at everything he's so cute he's
got to be adorable when he grows up no
the more I think about it it's not just
of my duty to keep that wallace in color
i do miss my nostrils it's my pleasure
but the more I think about it I wasn't
using them much anyway and that is the
essence I don't even have fingers to
hold the phone one of the kidnappers is
doing it for me don't you sure cares oh
you're fine you're fine
[Music]
[Applause]
you